Listening to radio lab radio from W. N y.
S. T. E. N. P. R,
please enter your address,
Colorado calculating route.
Okay, now I'm getting closer to him. Whew.
We begin our journey. The sour old are you? I'm 42. Oh Man, I'm 63.
This isn't gonna work. I don't know with this woman,
her name is Sharon Roseman. Okay. Enough of that.
And we're going to talk about a little but predicament. She got herself into.
Um, I was about five years old.
I lived in a small suburb of Chicago called Maywood,
Illinois.
And I was outside playing on the street or in a bunch of kids.
They were playing this game, blind man's bluff.
And she was the person who is it? Where's the blindfold?
And all the other kids try and scatter around and they have to freeze and then
they can turn to you and you can only hear them.
And the objective is basically to feel around,
follow the voices until you tag someone. Then they become it.
And that's what she does.
Everybody laughs because the person that I tagged as kind of the loser,
you know, cause they found them first.
So I'm playing the game and they took the blindfold off and suddenly
I didn't know where I was. I didn't recognize anything,
this horrible panic set in because nothing looked familiar to me.
Absolutely nothing. I just, uh,
I ran blindly just running, just to run,
cause I was so scared and I ran into the backyard of this house in front of me
and I saw my mother sitting in a lawn chair and I said,
why are you here? And she said, what? What do you mean? Why am I here?
I said, why are you in this backyard? Where are we? She said,
what are you talking about? We're at home. I'm in the back yard. And he said,
but this is in our house. And she said, yes,
this is what are you talking about?
And I couldn't explain it and I just kept crying and just kept saying,
I don't know where I'm at.
And your mother must've been very worried at that moment. Well,
unfortunately my mother said something to me that actually changed my life
forever. She pointed her finger in my face and she said,
don't ever tell anybody,
because they'll say you're a witch and they'll burn you. What?
Which I don't know. I don't know.
And from that moment on, it was my secret.
She realizes now that what happened to her in that moment when she was five and
playing the game was that her whole world had rotated.
The quarter turn a quarter turn picture where you're sitting right now. Yeah.
You would still be sitting in that same room,
but the wall that you're looking at right in front of you is now one wall over
to the right. Let me make it easier. If I were on the toilet,
say sitting there looking straight ahead.
[inaudible] is now the bath tub in a different place than it was before the sink
in a different place by about 90 degrees. Everything.
Everything in the entire universe, but just horizontally. It doesn't tilt or no,
it doesn't tilt. East West becomes north south, like in Colorado here,
the the mountains, the rocky mountains are on the west end of town. Right.
When this happens to me, they moved to the north end of town,
but everything else moves with it. So the first time that happened, did you,
you say you didn't know where you were yet, you recognize things,
but they just weren't where they were supposed to be or I didn't even recognize
them that very first time. I was so panicked. I just didn't know what to do.
Did it ever happen again? Over and over and over?
I mean, I get lost all the time as you, but that's loose is different. Yeah.
Before we go any further, let's just orient real quick. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab.
This hour we're calling it lost and found,
so I'm going to be experiencing the feelings like Sharon pat of being totally
lost and then that relief that you feel as Sharon will feel eventually of being
totally found.
Oh no, totally. Let's go back to her story. Did it ever happen again?
Over and over and over.
She says this 90 degree rotation problem would come on in all kinds of
situations. Sometimes even when she had her eyes closed.
But what saved me was that shortly after that first episode,
I went to a little birthday party and we were playing, um,
pin the tail on the donkey and they put a blindfold on me and spun me in
circles. You must've been like, oh man, you want to do that?
It was awful because after that first turn, everything did shift.
But then on the second turn, when they spun her around again, it fixed it.
Really? Yeah. Dizzy. That's so weird.
If I played a third time crazy again, so it's binary, it's like on, off, on,
off. Sadly. Exactly. But I couldn't tell anybody that,
but now she had a fixed or temporary fix. So from that moment on,
anytime her world would shift,
I would go into the bathroom and I'd close the door so nobody could see me and I
would spin in circles until it fixed it.
You spin and it reasserts itself correctly. Yeah.
And I still do that to this day, even in public stalls when she has to,
which can be humiliating because what would you think if you went into a
bathroom and you saw somebody,
somebody his feet going round and round and round.
In any case with this secret spinning techniques,
Sharon has sort of been able to get by. She got married, had three kids,
but when, when my children were babies, if one of them would cry out,
just cry out in their sleep. Invariably she'd wake up, Bang into a wall,
completely turned around. And then I would have to follow their cries,
the sound of their cries until I could find that their bedroom. Huh.
There was no explanation for that. I had to just say I was clumsy.
So you never told them? No,
and my husband didn't know and I'm not married to him anymore. But um,
and you can leave that in
the point is she kept it a secret. But
one day when Sharon was 29,
she was on her way to her brother's house and, uh, she got turned around.
So I called him from a pay phone and I said,
I can't find your house.
She read them the names of the street signs and he said, Sharon,
you're like two blocks from my house. And I,
I just started crying and I told them the story.
He was just shocked.
[inaudible]
so he dragged her to the hospital and they saw some specialists and they kept me
in, um,
in the hospital for like a week doing every kind of test you can imagine.
And it showed nothing.
They basically told me it was psychological.
Like it's all in your head. Yes. Wow.
And that you were the only one in the whole universe who had this problem?
Yeah, I thought, okay, I must be a witch.
[inaudible]
Huh? I mean that, that's, that's just, that's a crazy story. Okay.
Just to pull out for a bit, after we talked with Sharon,
we ended up speaking with them. Well, if you've heard Radiolab before,
you probably know that voice. Um,
Jonah Lehrer then let me ask you like a question.
Jonah Lehrer yes, there you go. Jonah is a science writer and an author.
My last book was how we decide there's a lot about the brain.
And so we played him tape from the Sharon interview just to see, we think,
and he had an interesting take. Well it's, I mean it just,
it just wanted these great windows into this talent we completely take for
granted. Um, and, and you realize this is such sophisticated software,
there's so many different algorithms that are running that allow us to not get
lost in the way to the bathroom.
One way to think about this story he says is not why does Sharon get lost all
the time? But why don't the rest of them exactly.
And a lot of this is brand new science. So we're talking the last three, four,
five years. But in that time he says,
scientists have just begun to figure out how brains make maps of our
surroundings from moment to moment.
They have identified at four different types of cells that make these maps
possible. Everything from place cells to grid cells to border cells.
Like can we go through ways? Cells? Yeah, no, no, we'll, we'll slow down. But,
but,
but all the cells come together to give us these incredibly rich messages.
All began to make more sense to us. When Jonah said, okay,
let me do it this way. I just took a trip into this office,
but I'm sitting in a radio station and let me do the same thing as I did it in
my brain. I got out of my car, I walked to the front of the building.
So I open up the door
and somehow some way my brain begins to make sense of this space.
First thing that happens. He says his little cells in his head called red cells.
Come on mind grid cells are pretty weird. I gotta be honest.
Before he's even taken the step into the building,
these grid cells kind of like mappers are surveyors. They just lay on a grid.
It's gray. This matrix over the hallway right in front of him.
Unbeknownst to me, that grid is composed of equal lateral triangles,
[inaudible] triangles. Yes. It's pretty spooky. As I'm walking
down the hallway, I passed from one triangle to the next.
My brain is keeping track of exactly which triangle I'm in.
I pass it by a wall so some border cells go off.
Avoid the concrete road, just respond to borders, edges,
physical limits. I look to my right and my head direction cells change,
but then they changed the ActiveWoo hid directions l so there is a head
direction neuron firing all the time when I'm facing.
Get ahead. When I turned my head to the left,
that neuron stops firing. We have a new head direction neuron firing.
Now I'm back to the deadhead.
I turned to the right new head direction on firing deadhead.
These cells keep you oriented so you know where you are in the grid and now it's
time to fill in the details and this is where things get really [inaudible].
Cool. Proceed down the Cardo as I take a couple more steps.
Now my place cells are probably beginning to get active.
It's the aim here, sal. It's like for every landmark in the space,
each body passes by the brain will drop a little. Yeah,
it's like an, I'm here,
people here at the coffee table and then I'm here at the potted plants and then
I'm here at the door in the studio.
So now as I imagine myself walking from this little closet,
like space back to my car,
as I pass by the coffee table with the magazines that plays so fires now and by
the front door, that place all fires. Now I'm on the sidewalk, that place.
So fires, now I'm buying my car. That place.
So fires and when you put it all together, the place sells the grid cells,
the borders, hills, what you get, he says just a symphony of electricity,
which somehow is translated for me
into an idea, a space,
and this whole neural symphony,
it mostly takes place in a particular part of the brain. Hippocampus.
So if Jonah were to just hazard a guess about Sharon,
she should get her hippocampus checked out, is what she should do. Mimi,
you know, that's just a guess. Now getting back to that story,
even though I was 29 I was an adult, I had children.
The point at which we left off, Sharon had gone to the hospital,
gotten a bunch of tests,
and the doctors had told her that I needed to go see a psychiatrist.
I felt like a freak.
Hello.
But then one day years after that I was watching some TV show.
Imagine scanning a crowd. It was a newsy 2020 type thing about face blindness,
blindness. People can recognize faces and at the end of the show,
the reporter mentions this website to the website. Sharon goes,
she was curious and when she gets there,
this little window pops up that asks [inaudible] she wants to take a survey.
So I thought, well, I'll do it.
And it was mostly questions about face recognition.
But as I got deeper and deeper into the questionnaire,
the question started turning more to have you ever experienced being in a,
a place that should look familiar to you but suddenly does not [inaudible] and I
was like, oh my gosh, that's me and asked for explanations.
So I was just typing away.
And typing away and eventually she meets the doctor who had finally d which her,
uh, my name is Jeff [inaudible].
I'm a cognitive neuroscientist at the University of Calgary.
And do you have a strong sense of direction and I'm curious, I don't actually,
I am, I'm not a gifted direction like you know in guy,
but just that
this idea that maybe just like face blindness,
there could be such a thing as location blindness.
So he asked Sharon to go online and play this game so to video games like
virtual reality,
not like where do you have to shoot people and find people and Blah Blah.
The screen would be showing you these landmarks like a flower shop and bar bank
bakery.
And then eventually I need it to be able to to say where things are with respect
to one another. Well No,
nothing man, not even a guess for me.
And it actually made me physically ill.
And then Giuseppe told her something before you, I'd met this woman,
this lady who has complained about orientation and she also failed this test.
So I brought her in to the lab and had her play the game in this counter in the
MRI scanner in the brain scanner and we were able to find activity all over the
brain except in one little place.
We were not able to detect any increased activity within the hippocampus,
which just so happens to be the home of Jonah's little guys play cell order
cells, grid cells. That
particular part of the brain and the hippocampus just never developed and at
that point that's when Giuseppe for the first time told her this thing has a
name d t d for developmental topographical disorientation
and that's not trivial because when something like this has a name,
suddenly it's not your fault. I felt like I was reborn. I keep telling him,
you are my hero, you'll always be my hero. Have you ever met Sharon?
I mean face to face and we are, we are supposed to meet now in this fall.
What if you like to meet her and fall in love with her and then she gets lost
and you rescue her and the science is ruined but you get married.
I am already married. Okay. Never mind. But anyway,
Giuseppe's there,
he's got a couple patients and he's wondering how many other folks like this are
out there. So he puts up a website. We said okay,
we are looking for people who have this specific symptoms.
One year later we were basically dealing with 700 people.
Oh shoot. Yeah.
So he sets up an Internet forum where they can all talk to each other.
I'm the moderator and now Sharon corresponds with DTD suffers from all over the
place. There are others out there who experienced the 90 degree rotation.
Oh, what about spinners though? Do you have, you've ever met at spinner?
Okay.
No, no, no.
Actually I should get some water cause if I love it. Oh here.
Well there's one there. That one, that's fine. Then do another one.
A few months later she did another woman named Sharon.
My name is Sharon Mitchell. The last name is m a C h. E. L rhymes with Rachel.
Okay. When this Sharon heard about the first Sharon,
she says she bolted straight up.
There is a woman in Colorado who has what I have and I,
it was such an emotional moment for me that she decided to fly to Colorado to
meet Sharon Roseman and they spent a day together. All right,
so let's just start with the easy stuff.
And they spoke with reporter Dave Vendor described yesterday. I mean,
what was it like to, uh, to get together yesterday and yesterday was awesome.
I got out of the car and we just gave each other a hug. And it was, it was,
it was a bond that I've never experienced with anybody else in my life ever.
No, we still don't know what's wrong with Sharon and Sharon and the others.
We certainly don't know how to fix it. But whereas before,
when Sharon and Sharon were lost and alone,
now they're lost and together this bond that we share.
So in a way it was wonder, it's like they're not really lost.
We sat down right away in the hotel lobby and started to laugh.
We couldn't stop laughing. Everything.
We were telling our experiences right away and comparing notes,
not even finishing our sentences.
These things that we laugh at or things that nobody else would think was funny.
Like we sat there probably for 15 minutes describing how we were going to
navigate from this hotel to the shopping mall that we could see right out the
window of the hotel. And we had to come up with some contingency plans. Yeah.
So we had, we had the gps if we needed it.
Sharon had a map in her hands if we needed it. We had street names.
We were just hoping that at least one of us was there instead of being messed
up. And so, um, we got there.
There it is. There it is. There it is weird. Most talks are jumping up.
It was really ridiculous. If anybody says,
and they have no clue why we were so excited that we found Nordstrom.
[inaudible]
big thanks to Molly Webster for producing that piece with us. And by the way,
you know the little kid's toy that's got a sit and spin oh yeah.
Where you sit on it and you go in circles and you get dizzy. Yeah. Okay. Well,
I want somebody to invent the, we're not being recorded, right? I mean,
this is, we are, but it's okay. Okay. I want the big ass sit and spin.
That would be so helpful to me.
I could just get up in the morning and just get on my little big asset and spin
and I could make my days much easy.